VIRGINIA GOVERNOR'S RACE AND THE
FORMER PRESIDENT ANSWERS THE
CALL TO HELP, BUT WE BEGIN IN
TEXAS TODAY WITH THE POLITICAL
CONFRONTATION THAT HAS A GIANT
PUBLIC HEALTH IMPACT.
NEW EXECUTIVE ORDER FROM
GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT BANS ANY
AND ALL BUSINESSES IN THE STATE
FROM MANDATING THE COVID
VACCINE.
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR SAYS THIS.
THE COVID-19 VACCINE IS SAFE,
EFFECTIVE AND OUR BEST DEFENSE
AGAINST THE VIRUS, BUT SHOULD
REMAIN VOLUNTARY AND NEVER
FORCED.
THIS IS A FULL ABOUT-FACE FOR
GOVERNOR ABBOTT.
WEEKS AGO HE SAID GOVERNMENT
SHOULD NOT TELL PRIVATE BUSINESS
WHAT TO DO, BUT IMPORTANT BUT
HE'S UP FOR RE-ELECTION NEXT
YORE AND HE'S THINKING ABOUT A
NATIONAL RUN IN 2024.
THIS NEW ORDER NOW PUTS HIM IN
SYNC WITH THE ANTI-MANDATE RIGHT
AND PUT HIM IN DIRECT CONFLICT
WITH PRESIDENT BIDEN.
CNN'S ED LAVANDERA KICKS US OFF
FROM DALLAS.
ED, A BIG MOVE BY THE GOVERNOR.
>> Reporter: INDEED, AND HE'S
ONCE AGAIN TAKING IT FROM BOTH
SIDES HERE AS DEMOCRATS ACCUSING
HIM OF MAKING A POLITICALLY
MOTIVATED DECISION THAT IS GOING
TO COST PEOPLE THEIR LIVES HERE
IN THIS STATE, AND ALSO HE HAS
BEEN TAKING A GREAT DEAL OF
CRITICISM FROM THE EXTREME RIGHT
WING OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
HERE IN TEXAS WHO HAVE BEEN
RAILING AGAINST VACCINE
MANDATES.
SO THE GOVERNOR ONCE AGAIN KIND
OF STUCK IN THE MIDDLE OF ALL OF
THIS POLITICALLY, AND IT'S CLEAR
TO A LOT OF PEOPLE HERE IN TEXAS
THAT THE POLITICAL MOTIVATIONS
BEHIND IS THE SUSPICION THAT'S
DRIVING GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT IN
THE SITUATION.
HE'S FACING TWO PRIMARY
OPPONENTS WHO HAVE BEEN RAILING
AGAINST VACCINE MANDATES, AND
THAT'S WHY MANY PEOPLE ARE
SAYING THAT THE DECISIONS THAT
WE'VE SEEN THE GOVERNOR MAKE
OVER THE LAST FEW WEEKS IS
LARGELY BASED IN THE POLITICAL
REALITY THAT HE FINDS HIMSELF
IN.
JUST LOOK AT THE LIST OF THE
BANS THAT THE GOVERNOR HERE HAS
ISSUED OVER THE LAST FEW WEEKS.
OBVIOUSLY BANNING PRIVATE
EMPLOYERS FROM VACCINE MANDATES,
A BAN ON GOVERNMENT VACCINE
MANDATES AS WELL AS PASSPORT
REQUIREMENTS, AND ALSO AFFECTING
SCHOOL DISTRICTS, AND WHAT IS
INTERESTING IN ALL OF THIS,
JOHN, IF YOU LOOK AT THE
POLITICAL FIGHT THAT THE
GOVERNOR WAS INVOLVED IN WITH
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS THE
STATE OVER MASK MANDATES AS THE
SCHOOL YEAR GOT UNDER WAY, YOU
SAW MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS WHO
SIMPLY IGNORED THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER.
THERE HAVE BEEN LAWSUITS BACK
AND FORTH, BUT MANY
ORGANIZATIONS CHOSE TO IGNORE
IT.
JOHN?
>> ED LAVANDERA, VERY IMPORTANT
STORY.
WE'LL CONTINUE TO TRACK IT IN
TEXAS.
LET'S BRING IN FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
CONTEXT THE FORMER BALTIMORE
CITY HEALTH COMMISSIONER.
GOVERNOR WEN, GOVERNOR ABBOTT
SAYS WE'RE TEXAS, DON'T MANDATE
THINGS AND WE'LL GET TO THE
FLIP-FLOP IN THE POLITICAL
CONVERSATION LATER.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE TRENDS MAP
RIGHT NOW IN THE COUNTRY, TEXAS
ONE OF THE STATES TRENDING DOWN.
MOST STATES ARE.
YOU SEE STATES THAT HAVE
INCREASING, RED AND ORANGE, MORE
NORTHERN STATES WHERE IT'S
GETTING COLDER.
IF YOU LOOK AT CORONAVIRUS CASES
WE WENT BACK TO THE END OF THE
MARCH WHEN THE DELTA VARIANT
FIRST TOOK ROOT IN THE UNITED
STATES AND YOU SEE UP HERE.
TEXAS, YES, IS AHEAD OF
CALIFORNIA AND NEW YORK WHEN IT
COMES TO CASES.
THE GOVERNOR MIGHT ARGUE NOT BY
SO MUCH, BUT TEXAS IS AHEAD,
MORE CASES THAN NEW YORK AND
CALIFORNIA.
LOOK AT HOSPITALIZATIONS.
TEXAS SIGNIFICANTLY AHEAD OF
CALIFORNIA AND NEW YORK.
IF YOU LOOK AT, AGAIN,
HOSPITALIZATIONS THROUGH THE
DELTA SURGE, IF YOU WILL, AND IN
DEATHS TEXAS IS ACTUALLY IN THE
MIDDLE, NEW YORK REPORTING MORE
DEATHS, SO LET'S COME -- LET'S
COME BACK -- DR. WEN AT THAT
POINT THERE, IF YOU'RE THE
GOVERNOR OF TEXAS, CAN IS THIS
JUSTIFIABLE, WE'RE TEXAS, WE'RE
THE WEST.
WE RIDE IT OUT.
IT'S NOT THAT MUCH WORSE THAN
ANYBODY ELSE, OR IS THIS IN YOUR
VIEW THE WRONG WAY TO GO?
>> THIS IS -- THIS FLIES IN THE
FACE OF PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDANCE
AND IS REALLY NOT THE RIGHT
THING TO BE DOING IN THE MIDDLE
OF A PANDEMIC.
AT THIS POINT WE KNOW WHAT WORKS
WHEN IT COMES TO KEEPING PEOPLE
SAFE.
WE KNOW PEOPLE WHO ARE
VACCINATED ARE AT LEAST FIVE
TIMES LIKELY TO BE INFECTED WITH
COVID COMPARED TO PEOPLE WHO RUN
VACCINATED AND SO IF YOU ARE AN
EMPLOYEE AND YOU'RE BEING ASKED
TO COME BACK INTO WORK, YOU
WOULD FEEL A LOT SAFER IF
EVERYBODY AROUND YOU IS ALSO
KNOWN TO BE VACCINATED, SO I
TRULY DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY ANY
GOVERNOR WOULD BE SAYING WE ARE
PROHIBITING BUSINESSES FROM
DOING THEIR PART TO KEEP THEIR
WORKERS AND THEIR CUSTOMERS
SAFE.
THESE ARE BUSINESSES THAT ARE
LISTENING TO THE REQUESTS OF
THEIR EMPLOYEES SAYING I DON'T
WANT TO GET COVID.
I DON'T WANT TO GET CORONAVIRUS
AND BRING IT BACK TO MY FAMILY.
THE BEST WAY FOR ME TO BE SAFE
IS YES, TO BE VACCINATED MYSELF
BUT ALSO TO BE SURROUNDED BY
OTHER PEOPLE WHO ARE VACCINATED
AND SO I REALLY HOPE THAT THE
GOVERNOR OF TEXAS AND OTHER
GOVERNORS DO THE RIGHT THING,
AND EVEN IF THEY DON'T DO THE
RIGHT THING, AT LEAST DON'T
STAND IN THE WAY OF BUSINESSES
WHO ARE TRYING TO PROTECT THEIR
WORKERS.
>> YOU JUST MADE A KEY POINT
THERE ABOUT THE BACK AND FORTH,
THE CONFLICT BETWEEN THE
GOVERNOR IN THIS CASE, MAYBE
BUSINESSES THAT WANT A MANDATE,
SEEN THAT CONFLICT BETWEEN
GOVERNORS AND MAYORS AND OTHER
LOCAL OFFICIALS WHO WANT IT
DIFFERENTLY.
I WAS PLAYING DEVIL'S ADVOCATE.
IT'S EVEN MORE TELLING.
COVID CASES ACROSS TEXAS
CUMULATIVELY YOU DO NOT WANT TO
BE RED, THE DARKER YOU ARE,
HARRIS COUNTY, FOR EXAMPLE,
HOUSTON, WHERE AUSTIN IS HERE,
TRAVIS COUNTY HERE, UP IN DALLAS
IT'S NOT QUITE THE SAME BUT IN
THE PLACES THAT HAVE DEFIED THE
GOVERNOR THE CASE COUNT IS
ACTUALLY LOWER, PLACES THAT HAVE
SAID LET'S WEAR MASKS, LET'S
HAVE SOME RESTRICTIONS.
IF YOU LOOK, THE CUMULATIVE
CASES TEND TO BE LOWER THAN IN
THE MORE CONSERVATIVE AREAS
WHERE THEY ACCEPT THE GOVERNOR'S
LET'S RIDE IT OUT, WE'RE TEXANS
APPROACH.
>> THESE ARE THE SAME TRENDS
THAT WE'RE SEEING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE CDC PUBLISHED A
STUDY THAT FOUND THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE MASK
MANDATES IN PLACE ARE THREE AND
A HALF TIMES LESS LIKELY TO HAVE
OUTBREAKS COMPARED TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT DO NOT HAVE MASK
MANDATES.
WE HAVE SEEN THIS THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY THAT MASK ROIRMTS
INDOORS REALLY HELP TO KEEP
CASES DOWN AND ALSO THAT
VACCINATION, THE HIGHER YOUR
VACCINATION RATES, THE LESS
LIKELY THAT YOU ARE THAT YOU'LL
HAVE OUTBREAKS THROUGHOUT THE
COMMUNITY EITHER, SO AT THIS
POINT, AGAIN, IT'S SO CLEAR THAT
THIS IS A PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE.
THIS SHOULD NOT BE A POLITICAL
ISSUE.
THIS REALLY IS ABOUT SAVING
LIVES AND LOOKING AT THE NUMBER
OF CASES AND SAYING HOW CAN WE
SAVE THE LIVES OF PEOPLE WHO
LIVE IN OUR AREA?
HOW CAN WE PREVENT THE -- THE
FURTHER SPREAD OF THIS DISEASE?
I HOPE THAT'S WHAT OUR ELECTED
LEADERS ARE CONSIDERING AT THE
END OF THE DAY.
>> I KNOW THAT IS YOUR HOPE.
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE ANOTHER
EXAMPLE OF A GOVERNOR DECIDING
NOT TO LISTEN TO THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EXPERTS.
WE'LL WATCH HOW THAT PLAYS OUT.
DR. WEN, THANKS SO MUCH.
POLITICAL ASPECTS.
WITH ME IN STUDIO TO SHARE THEIR
EXPERTISE, LET ME START WITH
JONATHAN MARTIN, DIDN'T THE
CONSERVATIVE POSITION BE THAT
DECISIONS SHOULD BE AT THE LOCAL
LEVELS, PARENTS SHOULD MAKE
DECISIONS AND THEN THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY AND NOT THE
GOVERNMENT.
WHAT HAS HAPPENED IN TEXAS?
>> WELL, NOW THE CONSERVATIVE
POSITION IS THAT YOU SHOULD TELL
THE COMPANIES NOT TO DO WHAT YOU
DON'T WANT THEM TO DO WHEN YOUR
GOVERNOR IS UP FOR RE-ELECTION.
>> YOU SHOULD MANDATE WHAT THEY
CAN'T MANDATE.
>> IT'S VERY HARD TO FOLLOW
BECAUSE IT'S NOT IDEOLOGICAL.
IT IS THIS IDEA THAT THERE IS A
BASE THAT IS VERY UPSET ABOUT
MANDATES.
THEY DON'T WANT VACCINES AND YOU
HAVE A GOVERNOR WHO IS WORRIED
ABOUT RE-ELECTION WHO IS SAYING
I HAVE TO GET OUT HERE AND LOOK
LIKE I'M READY FOR A FIGHT AND
I'M SURE HE WANTS TO FIGHT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON THIS.
THAT WILL BE IN HIS FAVOR.
>> HOW MUCH -- BEROURKE TWEETING
THIS, 68,000 TEXANS HAVE DIED
FROM COVID ON ABBOTT'S WATCH.
MORE WILL DIE AS HE PREVENTS
EMPLOYERS FROM PROTECTING
EMPLOYEES.
ABBOTT IS KILLING TEXANS.
DR. WEN IS MAKING A POINT AND
WE'VE LEARNED OVER THE LAST YEAR
PLUS.
POLITICS AND COVID ARE IN FULL
COLLISION ALL ACROSS AMERICA.
>> THIS IS THE BIG STORY OF OUR
TIME THAT UNLIKE PAST NATIONAL
TRAGEDIES WHICH HAVE SORT OF
CREATED AN EFFECT IN THE
COUNTRY, HAS HAD AN OPPOSITE
FACT, PULLED APART THE COUNTRY'S
RED AND BLUE DIVISIONS, MADE
THEM EVEN WORSE, AND THAT HAS
SORT OF ADDED TO THE -- TO THE
TRAGEDY ITSELF, BUT WE NOW HAVE
A PUBLIC HEALTH TRAGEDY AND A
CIVIC TRAGEDY IN THIS COUNTRY,
AND YOU CAN SEE IT GETTING WORSE
STILL EVERY DAY.
>> AND IT'S WITHIN THE STATE OF
TEXAS, RIGHT, SO THERE'S GOING
TO BE A VERY DIFFERENT RESPONSE
TO THIS IN DALLAS, IN THE
SUBURBS OF DALLAS THAN THERE
WILL BE IN RURAL PARTS OF TEXAS,
AND THE CALCULATION IS, AT LEAST
FOR NOW, THE BLUE PARTS OF
DALLAS ARE NOT BIG ENOUGH TO
OVERCOME THE RED PARTS OF THE
REST STATE.
THERE ARE OTHER STATES, VIRGINIA
BEING AN EXAMPLE, WHERE THE BLUE
PARTS HAVE GOTTEN BIGGER AND THE
RED PARTS ARE SHRINKING, SO THIS
IS THE FIGHT THAT WE'RE GOING TO
SEE NOT JUST ON COVID BUT ON
EVERY ONE OF THESE CULTURAL
ISSUES.
ARE YOU FIGHTING FOR RED AMERICA
OR FOR BLUE AMERICA?
>> AND IN THE PRIMARY.
ABBOTT HAS A PRIMARY FIRST.
HAS TO SURVIVE THAT TO GET TO
THE GENERAL SO THAT'S TOPIC "A"
FOR HIM.
>> SO "THE HOUSTON CHRONICLE"
SET OUT ABBOTT IS FACING HIS
FIRST SERIOUS PRIMARY CHALLENGES
WHO HAVE MADE COVID-19 ONE OF
THE BIGGEST ISSUES.
I'M GOING TO CALL THE GOVERNOR
TACKING RIGHT, TACKING TO WHERE
THE BASE OF THE PARTY IS.
THERE'S ALSO THIS IF YOU LOOK AT
HIS RECENT HISTORY, TRIED TO
POSITION HIMSELF, THE GOVERNOR
OF FLORIDA RON DeSANTIS IS I'M
THE ANTI-BIDENCH THEY HAVE SOME
HOPE THAT TRUMP DIS-AUSTIN
POWERS AND IF YOU LOOK RECENTLY
TEXAS GOVERNOR ABBOTT'S WERE
BANNING VACCINATIONS AND THE
TEXAS ABORTION LAW IN THE
HIGHLIGHTS THERE, ABBOTT
PROMISED THAT THE BORDER AGENTS
NOT BE PUNISHED BY THE BIDEN
STRAIGHTS.
JOE BIDEN SAYS YES SO I SAY NO.
>> EVERY STEP OF THE WAY.
GOVERNOR ABBOTT HAS BEEN AGAINST
JOE BIDEN IN EVERY STEP OF THE
WAY WITH EVERY COVID
RESTRICTION.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT SETS UP,
YOU KNOW, POSSIBLY A LEGAL
CHALLENGE THAT THEY CAN TAKE
IN